yeah this weekly third all the way back
to the 90s and play with Tamagotchis I
honestly don't know how long I've had my
original Tamagotchi
I actually was a tamagotchi hoarder I
got like an eel pet or a Giga pet
because it was like free and a happy
meal or something has just lost the
tooth and decided that night that I was
gonna write a letter to the Tooth Fairy
saying that instead of a quarter I think
it'd be really cool she brought me a
Tamagotchi me my brother got them
because my mom told us that we had to
keep her Tamagotchi is alive in order to
get a dog we both killed her Tamagotchis
but we still ended up getting a dog so I
don't know how that lesson really worked
out if lo a guy just showed up on my
desk and without any instructions so
excited to let this open and start
taking care of it and really hope I
don't kill it the new version is super
duper small so I'm excited to see how
it's gonna be
[Music]
I'm gonna pull this tab right now which
is like the best feeling ever and bring
him to life juggling this and work is a
little tough I have to find a babysitter
when I'm going to a really important
meeting because I don't want it to go
off when I'm on a call Nancy Liz is
taking care of my time I got you IV I'm
feeding him apparently my tomowachi was
beeping and I had my headphones on at
work so Tanner yelled at me yeah it was
crying she was ignoring it
she's a bad Tamagotchi mom Tanner are
you might tempt ad for the Tamagotchi me
and gachi is what I call my Tamagotchi
for sure had truly one of the best
weekend's of our lives we will head out
in the East Village we walked the
Brooklyn Bridge we went to the Giants
game we shared the most beautiful New
York weekend I feel like I've had
supernatural experiences with my
Tamagotchis and this one wasn't an
exception I'm honestly kind of tired of
taking care of him because there's
nothing that exciting that's happening
oh my god he totally hurt me did you see
that oh my god she's just like he
listens like he's in there you see it's
like it knows every time I call him
boring every single time a poop came up
I just laugh cuz there's nothing more
funny than poop something happened
he's got like four poops I'm gonna clean
up his poops right now oh he's so much
happier randomly would message like
would start pinging me if I was sitting
there not doing anything I'd be like
clean my poop [ __ ] it did not go as I
expected I love my Tamagotchi I'm super
nervous because I lost my Tamagotchi I
looked at home I looked in my desk but I
can't find it like anywhere but I did my
best but I did find it right this is
dead I just you know some people aren't
meant to parent things in life and I
realized that you only fight me and got
you got and this week was when he woke
me up at like 7:00 a.m. just begging for
food morning my Tamagotchi won't stop
beeping it's so annoying no one wants to
pick it up and play with the buttons and
feed it and kind of relive that joy they
had when they were a kid it definitely
brought back memories that I hadn't
really thought about since I moved here
one guy actually next to me on the
subway who heard the beep go off and
then like turned to me and was like whoa
that sound just brought me back straight
to the nineties even though the
experience wasn't as exciting as I
expected I was happy to wave like I used
to when I was a kid these used to means
so much to me because they were kind of
like my friends on the go so it was just
cool to think about that Deana gachi
daddy was fun clearly I'm not cut out to
be a parent it made me miss being a kid
and just like having fun hanging out and
laughing about cleaning up my
Tamagotchis poop really brought me back
to my roots you know put it on my teaser
that I love to clean up Tamagotchi food
it was so fun
[Music]